i'm debbie mazar and i play maggie i'm
niko tortorella i play
josh i'm molly bernard and i play lauren
i'm peter herman and i play charles i'm
sutton foster and i play liza miller
and this is the cast of younger here to
answer your
burning questions
what were my first impressions of my
castmates and did they
change over the years wow my first
impression
of sutton foster uh was uh oh
she knows my line better than me
i had scenes with her mostly in the
pilot and
she she comes from theater theater
and i haven't done a lot of theater so i
was sort of like not intimidated but she
had this other
it was like a whole other worldly thing
going on where she
i can i could see her in her brain
remembering the pages and
i was like oh my god and i had like my
little tiny sides in my hand
she was just like so happy and
and nerdy and and cool at the same time
and i just was like oh wow this is gonna
be great
i didn't know what to think about lizzie
mcguire oh my god like my kids watched
lizzie mcguire i never got to watch it
hillary duff she's like an la girl
and then when she came on set she was
like a bad like she was like
pro tough mama fierce and funny
nico for me he was like this he was
younger i mean when you looked at the
footage
of when we first started i was like whoa
look you you were all shaved and
young but you were you were always um to
me sort of like a little brother in
sweet
and smart and you had always had this
big curiosity and this big
laughter and the same with molly like
molly to me when she first walked in the
set she was this
sort of hummingbird like creature with
these big eyes
and then there is peter herman and when
he walked on this set
i was sort of intimidated because he's
so beautifully
tall and gorgeous and quiet and
intellectual and
actually no nobody was um weird or mean
and i just felt i could finally have fun
here like
and we all i found everyone to be so
generous right at the get-go so that was
you know wonderful despite being floored
to meet my idol sutton foster and then
being upset to talk about her bush
on like national television i was such a
prude i was like this
is awful i did not meet nico until
episode maybe 11. i remember thinking
oh you're a very different person than
you
were then i felt very intimidated by you
like you were like a a hollywood like
guy right and then over the course of
our friendship you're
you've become like one of my best like
softest
almost like girlfriends basically what
i'm trying to say in a not
the most successful way my first
impression of you could not have been
more different
than where our friendship has gone it's
really not i would say the same thing
about you not
not the hollywood guy but you know full
transition
girl she is she is blossom she is a
falcon
from hummingbird to falcon
and compared to our impressions now i
mean we've been on the show for seven
years
you know we have all grown
together as a unit and separately in our
own private lives like so much has
happened over this time
and i just love everyone more than i did
back then what was our favorite
storyline throughout the seasons it
happens this season
that i can't talk about because people
haven't seen it
um so but there's so there's my favorite
storyline
is coming up i will i'll answer the the
the question sort of
it's sort of a pun to sort of a general
way my favorite storyline
is the writers the line that they were
able to walk
between uh humor and really pushing the
envelope which
kept sending me to urban dictionary to
find out what
what things like oh god were there any
difficult scenes
to film i think to the blind eye it
seems like oh it's all fun and games and
it's you know all glamorous and la dee
da
the days are very long the scenes are
often quite complicated
uh and they usually have a lot of
different parts and shots and setups to
them for me personally
i think it was season five lauren was
sleeping at the
like female club based off of the wing
called the nest
i had this emotional scene with hill in
the bathroom of that female club
and the line failure is not an option i
just thought about for days and days and
days leading up to it i need to make
sure that like we see that she's
suffering but it's not a drama
learning how to modulate that was a real
learning moment for me but
that was my hardest scene suddenly i had
a lot of
tense moments over the years whenever we
would show up to set and we knew that we
had that scene like we couldn't even
look at each other
tears were there it was about to go down
those days were the hardest for me for
sure and
most rewarding i would say the moments
where i got to see you guys acting in
front of me and then
also see the monitor you could like cut
the tension with a knife we were so
lucky to see those
but i really hated it was like every
scene where like there was a whole
season
where hillary and i every scene was like
that was the worst right her character
was so mad at me that's the thing is
like
everyone gets every season everyone's
mad at me
so we have like all these like fights
debbie you and i
like maggie and liza are always pretty
good and who's hard for me is always
being the one in the kitchen
is either stirring something that's not
actually there
pouring like grape juice white wine or
club soda we are making coffee
and i'm like get me out of this
apartment jaron
i can make it look real but it just got
boring after a while and i got the gift
of getting
a subway scene which i asked for for
seven seasons and at least this season
my god
so we had so many amazing uh amazing
guest stars and recurring characters
an incredible list i think my favorite
might have been josh pace
who plays lauren's father i i don't
quite know how to describe it this
impish expertise to his delivery this
season he gets
he gets hammered and he challenges
someone to a push-up contest
and i can't remember what the line was
but it was utterly original
never been said before that was the case
with every one of his lines somehow
just so wonderfully well done and then
there was also kristin chenoweth's
sl she can do a slow one-eyed wink which
is
super creepy oh yeah molly can do it too
yes god that's weird we also have janine
garofalo this season
is amazing
you're forgetting about kathy and jamie
who's a national treasure
how do i feel about how the characters
story lines have ended and how do i see
their futures i echo what peter said is
that i really feel like the writers
um took good care of everybody and i
will
say that i read the final script i can't
say anything
but i read the file script and which
they gave us like the day before the
final table read because the writers are
[ __ ] and they won't tell us anything
and they would always like withhold
everything
and so we would we wouldn't know and
we're all like reading them on our
phones like trying to get through
and i finished the final script and i
was like
deeply satisfied i felt like it was
incredibly satisfying and incredibly
true
to the story and to my character
there is an ending but it's not an
ending it's like a pause you know
so like you can't help but think what's
next
i don't know what the next decade will
be oh that's what that's
nico and i we're gonna we're we're
producing the movie the younger movie
right
yeah a limited series coming soon we're
not
i feel like we're not done with these
characters maybe a little less drama
filled for liza like she's had some
pretty drama filled
you know seven years of some drama so
maybe some you know maybe some boring
some nice just like happiness and like
[Music]
success
[Music]
you